10 millions d'euros c'est le montant de
l'aide qui a choisi de verser la famille
de Bernard Arnault au resto du coeur en
proie à de grandes difficultés
financières ce dimanche l'association
révélait sa peine à faire face à l'effet
combiné de l'inflation et de la hausse
des bénéficiaires le don du patron du
groupe LVMH ne donnera lieu à aucune
contrepartie ni à aucune défiscalisation
après si c'est un porte-parole de la
famille Arnaud qui compte soutenir une
magnifique association d'intérêt général
qui œuvrent pour les plus fragiles
depuis près de 40 ans si rien n'est fait
on pourrait devoir fermer d'ici trois
ans c'est le constat alarmant qu'elle
est formulé dimanche le président des
restos Patrice dourets l'association qui
assure 35% de l'aide alimentaire en
France c'est résigner cet hiver à
réduire son nombre de bénéficiaires
menaçant de laisser pour compte près de
150 000 personnes en cause la hausse
très importante du nombre de personnes
qui demandent de l'aide et une
augmentation de ses coûts de
fonctionnement dû à l'inflation depuis
le début de cette année les restos du
cœur ont déjà accueilli 1,3 millions de
personnes contre 1,1 million sur
l'ensemble de l'année 2022 mal de le
durcissement de ces critères
d'éligibilité l'association s'attend à
servir 170 millions de repas cette année
contre 140 millions en 2022 ces derniers
mois son budget pour les achats
alimentaires redistribués ensuite
gratuitement au bénéficiaires a été
multiplié par deux c'est un véritable
crèche-cœur mais nous allons devoir
massivement dire non à des personnes que
nous aurions pu accueillir avant
l'inflation et nous allons devoir
réduire la quantité de ce que nous
donnerons aux personnes qui rentreront
dans nos critères les restos disposent
d'un budget de fonctionnement d'environ
200 millions d'euros par an provenant de
donateurs particuliers d'entreprises
ainsi que d'aide publique aujourd'hui
elle a besoin de 35 millions d'euros
supplémentaires pour terminer l'exercice
à l'équilibre face à cela un appel aux
forces politiques et économiques de
notre pays pour le lancement d'un plan
d'urgence alimentaire a été lancé par
Patrice douret invité ce dimanche au
journal TV de TF1 cela fait des mois
qu'on alerte le gouvernement sur cette
situation on n'a pas assez été entendu
le cri de détresse de cette association
emblématique créée en 1985 par le
comédien français connu a fait réagir la
classe politique et économique la
ministre des Solidarités Aurore berger à
d'ores et déjà promis une aide publique
supplémentaire de 15 millions d'euros
tandis que plusieurs géants de la
distribution dont Carrefour et Leclerc
se sont dit prêt à répondre à l'appel
pour faire face à l'urgence et permettre
aux structures de poursuivre leur
soutien auprès des plus démunis le
Crédit Mutuel alliance fédérale a quant
à lui décidé de donner 7,5 millions
d'euros pour la croix rouge ainsi que 5
millions pour les banques alimentaires
[Musique]